okay you know what jquery is no i don't
know what
you need to think about yourself
sometimes before you start insinuating
yourself and other people's bidding well
you know what
denies i'm gonna insinuate my stuff
whenever and wherever i please cause
it's a free country
[ __ ]
okay you know what oh we're doing this
okay so we're gonna do here babe
yeah we are about to fight now bring it
on there [ __ ]
call me a [ __ ] again oh yeah call me a
[ __ ] okay
no your wish is great oh see what he
would have i would like to see what
happens
i would love to see what happens
oh you do oh absolutely so why don't you
come and bring it then [ __ ]
see no you are writing my last nerve
and i ain't even playing no more i am
not
even playing no more oh it's all then
let's do something okay
you want to go do something
[ __ ] huh there we go let's
do something
let's do something [ __ ] what
we told you not to mess with us [ __ ]
y'all just saw that [ __ ] turn into two
little girls right